au milieu des 300 participants du
bakenron de sérieux concurrents à la
victoire peaufine leur tactique de
course en pleine préparation hivernale
les triathlètes de l'équipe élite du
club 50 chinois participent à la fête
son réel objectif de performance on va
pouvoir s'encourager ses plonger un
petit peu le front celui qui est sur le
VTT il va pouvoir bichonner un peu le
corps à pied et puis voilà l'important
c'est aussi de se faire plaisir de
partager un bon moment avec tout le
monde c'est un petit peu le lancement de
la saison donc ça fait toujours plaisir
de revenir un peu en terre connue ici à
Saint-Quentin
le Bike & Run et l'exercice numéro 1
pour enchaîner les efforts intenses
au-delà des 15 km/h et dans un laps de
temps très court un rythme difficile à
encaisser pour un duo below brandré sans
trop de repère physique au final les
triathlètes 50 chinois restent maître
sur leur terre le tandem Pozzo di Borgo
boxe s'impose en 35 minutes de course
c'était difficile dès le début parce
qu'on commence par une côte en fait il y
a une côte de à peu près 600 mètres donc
dès le début il faut il faut se mettre
dans le rythme puis après le parcours
est assez roulant mais du coup ça nous
oblige à toujours courir à
une vitesse régulière et c'est assez
fatigant
huitième à l'arrivée les cadors de
l'équipe élite on termine les jambes un
peu lourdes on a la caisse on manque
encore un peu de vitesse mais du coup
c'est peut-être ce qui nous a pénalisé
aujourd'hui mais bon c'est pas trop
grave c'est pas toi Thomas qui t'a
limité un peu ouais c'est peut-être
l'état de fraîcheur par rapport aux
autres concurrents mais bon c'est
c'était aussi le but de venir ici faire
une bonne séance voilà la victoire il
tenteront de la décrocher lors du
premier Grand Prix de France fin mai et
faire rentrer le club de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans le top 5
France